will it achieve artificial general
intelligence and become Superior to
humanity it already is in every one of
the narrow tasks we've assigned to them
they are by far the winners think about
it this way CH GPT 4 had an IQ of 165
that's basically Elon Musk IQ Einstein
is I think 162 because none of us is
comparable to Einstein people would say
oh but it's stupid it's just predicting
the next word yeah we are stupid that's
exactly what we do as well humanity is
so arrogant in those topics because in
all honesty remember the first days when
you joined a new company and all that
you did was remember the three-letter
words and repeat it the next word